ま、コメント欄で自民党について校長の
意見をもう少し聞きたいっていうのが
多かったので伺いたいです。
自民党はね、真がないやないか。だから
自民党の中にリベラルまでおるやないか。
国民全般は自民党を頼りにしとると思う。
それこそリベラルとか共産党とかどう見
たって嘘ばっかり言っとるということ
ぐらい分かるわね。誰が見ても。で、特に
いかんのは実現不可能なことばっかり言う
よね。減税しろっていうのは簡単や。で、
減税た分収入が減る。それをどうするんや
ということをちゃんとあれせやんね。その
上で言わないいかんのに。ただ現在しろ、
しろ、そうしたら景気が良くなるって。
ちょっと考えれんわ。全体に不勉強なんや
ね。自民党はどういう方向性で結いですか
ね?まず大和魂を勉強しろよ。それほど
素晴らしい精神論はないんだということが
よくわかってヤ和魂を身につけてそれから
いろんなことを考えていけよ。そうしたら
大したもんになるんだけどもリベラル
ばっかり揃っとるような感じがするよね。
今見ると頼りにならんやんからマスコミ
なんか恐れてどうするんや。トランプ見て
みや。平気でマスコミと喧嘩するやないか
。全部フェイクニュースだって言うじゃん
。全部フェイクニュースだよ。だけど自民
党の議員で日本のマスコミが全部フェイク
ニュースだということがはっきりと分かる
ものがおるかな。いやしないやろ。あいつ
はヤ和魂を身につけてたら全部フェイク
ニュースだということが分かるんやら。
そういうね全てが戦教育によってこんな風
になっちゃう。日本人全体がザメになった
んやから。特に男がザメになったんやから
。しっかりした男になろうよ。みんなを
リードしようって言ってる人間がへな
チョコでどうするんや。
校長が自民党の議員とかこれまでの政治家で大和魂を身につけていてしっかり尊敬できる人物っていらっしゃるんですか?
いや、俺もう全然そういう政治の面も経済の面も詳しく見たことないもんでな。あれだけど戦後日本を引っ張っていった人たちやないからともかくあやってゼロでされてな。ゼロよりマイナスよね。そっから世界トップまで引っ張り上げていった人たちがいたわけやん。その人たちこそ男やないかな。
それを野党が散々攻撃したやろ。あいつらの方がおかしい。お前らできたのと。野党の連中には決してできんわな。自民党のあい男らしい連中が偉い人やっとったからこそできたことや。
次の選挙とかだと自民党がさらにピンチになるんじゃないかって言われてたりするんですけど
ねえ。どうも石葉さん情けな。ふにゃーっとしとるよね。黙って俺についてこいという風やないといかんねん。黙って俺についてこいという自信のある人はね、正しい人に決まっとるんや。
間違っとる人はほのって言えんからね。
千葉さんはなんかフラフラす、フラフラ
するよね。喋り方もなんかこう信用できる
んやろかというような喋り方するしな。
言い訳をする人はいかん。開き直らん。
それの何が悪いんだと言えるようにならん
とな。大体マスコミというのはイチもん
ばっかりつけとるんだからイチもつけると
いう言えんといかんわな。
自民党の理由の憲法の改正は今はもう
あんまりでは言われてないんですかね。
ほとマスコミが反対するし、マスコミが
怖が彼らの1番のはね、マスコミを怖がる
ことや。なんで怖がるどころか制服しとる
わな。マスコミに対してからもう日本の男
の1万かんのはそこや。裁判官でもそう
やろ。マスコミの言う通りの判決を下す
やろな。裁判官のあれがないやないか。
信用できへんよね。マスコミが信用でき
へんのに。そのマスコミの言うことを信用
するっていう意味やからね。裁判所が我々
は偉い時代に生きとるんや。
立法がえかと言うと立法はさえもマスコミに復しとるやろ。マスコミ自体はアメリカに乗っられとるわけやろ。それもうアメリカの意のままだ。
トランプさんとかが今めちゃくちゃ対当してるのもアメリカのマスコミへの信頼感が由来できたとかも
リベラルに対して信頼感が由来いたんよね。あれでそう言っとった。あのアメリカに住んどる先輩に聞いてみたらほんだら絶対トランプが勝つよっていう。で、どうしてって言ったらリベラルの信用がなくなっちまっとる。
嘘ばっかり言うもんね。綺麗事ばっかり
言ってね。リベラルの1番いかんのは常に
上から目線やないか偉そうにね。だから
あの大学の学生とかなんかがこうやって
髭生やしてリベラルやっとるわね。もう
現場の叩き上げのすごいやつが出てくると
リベラルはもう手も足も出ら今度の
イーロンマスクなんていうのはあ大償
みたいなやつやないか。それが公務員を首
にするんだよってやってそれに対する批判
ないもんね。日本でないやないか。
アメリカはどうなんか知らんけどな。今
までやったらとんでもないことだ言って
公務員をやめさせるとは何事だと大騒ぎ
するやろ。先生をやめさせようとしたもん
だ。ああいうこと言い出したんやね。けど
向こうが先に先生はどっかの政党に偏っ
とってはいかんやろ。中理な立場で教育せ
ないかんよね。それがもう完全に左に傾い
とったやないか。それ理由でもやめさし
たってええやろ。日教育なて日況全員首で
ええやないか。それができんやったんやね
。これが自民党のダメなとこよね。